if anybody does anything crazy you are
fired
Rita tell him to chill out because I'm
leaving tonight if you talk to me I'm
really leaving Ramsay now calling chef
of calling them Ramsay and that sort of
call mr. Ramsay at least call them mr.
Lutz
listen respect he deserves he's coming
my life he's already [ __ ] on the food
like I'm waiting for him to see us we're
on the front of the house and yell at us
about that
Doug tiramisu on no can't be bothered
nope no can't be bothered
Wow anyway so take me through the line
who's running what station but we
usually don't work in stations you don't
work with stations either holy [ __ ]
they're worse every Saturday night
Boston's North End is packed
how are you early and as a result it's
the one night that the Galleria 33 is
filled with customers my name is Sarah
and I'm gonna be your server tonight
Francesca my God my nerves
[Music]
sir whenever it's ready we can take
table one dunk who talks to who Kukui
cakes there
[Music]
anybody just communicator I will I do
but I can't hear anything
who's who's when things aren't ready we
just put them over there are so reserved
because of their timing when that's
ready we I said this already checking
out Fredo chicken gallery yeah coming
[Music]
just you just dropped that on the floor
you just dropped on the floor
yeah you just dropped on the floor now
Rita Lisa both you two two seconds so
this is sending me crazy
hello what you just dropped the chicken
on the floor I put it back in the pan
this one here come on guys wait a minute
he dropped it on the floor and cocked it
that's the one that dropped on the floor
it's all game good enough to win it I'm
not here to make you look stupid don't
wait for stop a chef nice Irving [ __ ]
chicken they dropped me off floor I mean
all I see you guys look like a bunch of
[ __ ] idiots
first thing eggplant tower okay then
I'll have the chicken wrap shrimp please
finally some fish would recommend the
Salmons fresh it comes with potatoes and
vegetables are passed any pass do you
like but you wouldn't sell spaghetti
with the salmon
you have people get it all the time cuz
I like to take the pasta home usually
let's go for the salmon spilling on ice
okay excellent thank you wow you got it
over there table turns appetizers please
I'm very excited to show Chef Ramsay
what I can do I feel that there will be
no faults in what I produced one go wow
eggplant power my co-host when Chef
Ramsay's appetizer coming out you can
see his face like what is this [ __ ] I
said oh my God we're dead
that's definitely not homemade
mozzarella is ghastly
stone cold solid and tasteless how are
you madam how was dinner
fair hope you're in the bag what is that
Oh lovely when will you have this for
lunch tomorrow
so you're not coming back tomorrow
because you got dinner there thank you I
like your lipstick
wait spending time in the company of the
Golden Girls exactly
[Laughter]
Kevin bring it out wow shrim thank you
chicken and shrimp well got the chicken
and where's the shrimp bingo I'm talking
with that looks like chicken tastes like
shrimp or [ __ ]
judge my solo
I've never had a shrimp that hard why
don't you stick the shrimp inside of
chicken it's one of his creations I
guess
okay you ready Jesus oh yes thank you
thank you Jesus your shrimp was too hard
rock hard like a bullet
okay it is why would you put shrimp
inside of a chicken he says I don't get
it all right
[Music]
when I first this came back I was I was
I was disgusted pissed off I wanted to
prove him wrong I wanted to show my
cooking skills you know are up to par
that's the Balinese thank you thank you
okay christ almighty
dry and absolutely hideous pretty sight
let's go dry pretty dry okay would you
mind just how would you like another
piece another day okay
if salmon was too dry he didn't want
another piece he said this was brutal
there you go taste throw it out when it
came back now is just too pissed off to
even taste it I was furious if Chef
Ramsay saying that my field of [ __ ]
personally I feel that it's the wrong
opinion at this point I'm [ __ ] furious
I'm furious
stop jerking around shrimp as the first
orders come into the kitchen okay
Kingston cafes complimentary salads get
sent out to the diners Michael first
course comes with every meal soon to be
a little similar [ __ ] is that a martini
glass salad Daniel yes put the salad in
a martini glass is there a doctor in the
house
how many glasses this trays in the
corner there that they take oh my god
you are kidding me Jesus Christ who do
all this oh my good god
I'm Gordon if you continue like that
Jesus Christ actually gonna appear I
hope so because I think that's what's
needed right now dressing a salad take
seconds tell me what's wrong with that
they get soggy and it's a nasty turn
around and tell the owner it's soggy and
it's nasty that doesn't mean that it's
really bad because he's never seen
something like this before
and when you dress the salad in a bowl
okay even though he was just planning on
observing Chef Ramsay can't control
himself and Institute's his first change
fresh salads dress to order and in a
bowl well done thanks but dr. Morrison
make sure that Islam is still the woman
in charge can you give a better piece of
micromanaging whenever and wherever
possible
since I'm making it there's no taste
another piece of chicken I don't like
you don't like this okay
like we said up to old people right here
they're not Jamaican they're not gonna
like it
dr. Morris doesn't really like to hear a
lot of complaints about the food she
does what she knows or wants to do
what is that there
chicken breasts yes what was that yeah
that was cooked yesterday doctor yes I
can't believe we're doing this
that was cooked last night's tongue
makes me feel validated I guess that the
points that I've been making for months
are the points that he's making now Jeff
a dog at home don't feed them that you
only just come over here okay now he
oniy is really getting me very upset
suppose a punch him out because let me
finish
he's right okay finish Jionni all he did
keone please be quiet
first of all he want us to cook
everything fresh why can't you do that
you just can't Jamaican food cannot be
cooked fresh every day do you understand
that
mom we'll finish this later
[Music]
what is that there oh my god you are
kidding me
thanks everywhere christ almighty oh
please
what's on the microwave right
when I first worked here I was like oh
no really
bags come on what's the addiction to
back is that a medical thing like
donating blood and bags are everything
we'd always like in back where do you
want to put it there maybe now who tell
me that rice tastes better in a bag
inside the steamer madam I'm really
sorry
well you've lost the plot I don't like
when you disrespect me so if you can
tell me where you think I've
disrespected you you told me that I was
crazy upstairs I'll tell you why the
practices and how you're running a
restaurant is packed with stupidity I
didn't say that you are demented
insanely like that's all
no you specifically say like let me
finish I say that to you how does you
see I'm not a delicate dainty clouds
gonna take everything you say personally
but let me tell you something the
practices are ludicrous can I just show
you something no answer just just feel
that it's frozen no no no don't tell me
okay another show no I've got to lose my
sentence frozen solid
disgusting overcooked chicken you're
resisting it that's fun I'm trying to
say it should not be close-knit they did
rise today and is that okay but I just
told you it is right now you're running
a hospital kitchen full of bags
[ __ ] that I'm out of it he may say I'm
crazy but certain things he says about
you making food I disagree with him I'm
not crazy I think a doctor needs a
doctor